Hey, I'm Chad. I've been rod. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and today we are, um,
we're celebrating and a multiple set of anniversaries because it was 80 years
ago, 80 years ago,
that Orson wells and the mercury theater decided to allow Martians to invade the
State of New Jersey.
It's one of the most famous broadcasts in broadcast history because it freaked
people out. Yes.
And then, uh, merely 10 years ago, uh,
we decided to take another look at this broadcast,
which has gotten very complicated and layered and disputed in some ways over
time.
We're now celebrating our 10th. They're celebrating their 80th.
So along with Orson Wells, who am I afraid couldn't be here tonight,
leaving the rest in peace. Yes.
We would like to present our homage to a,
I guess two microbes really to the little earthlings that saved the planet,
right? So
in honor of the microbes in honor of a war of the worlds which broadcast 80
years ago, a today, tonight,
here is our take on war of the worlds.
[inaudible]
October 30th, 1938 on that night,
the United States experienced the kind of mass hysteria that we'd never seen
before.
And the reason which today is sounds almost comical was a radio play.
Really.
I did say to him with an orphan wells and the mercury Federer on the air and the
war of the world,
[inaudible]
around 12 million people were listening. Most got the joke.
It was Halloween after all.
But if you consider that about one out of every 12 people didn't get the joke.
That's what surveys found afterwards about one out of every 12 people who heard
the broadcast thought it was true,
and that some percentage that 1 million people ran out of their homes,
towels over their faces, clutching children, tripping, breaking limbs. Well,
that constitutes a major freak out.
[inaudible]
and then this is our first ever live hour on radio lab here at Saint Paul,
Minnesota at the Fitzgerald Theater. We ask why,
why did people panic?
And of course we'll ask the big question as well, which is Canon happen again.
I'm Jad Abumrad thank you all for coming in.
Where's my [inaudible]?
So let me [inaudible] I mean,
let me just say at the outset,
I'm just a tiny bit of puzzle before you do we just tell it,
tell everyone who you are. Yeah, I'm Robert. Can you just say Robert Crow,
which is my name and uh, with all due respect,
I mean if we had any number of things we could have done in the hour,
could've done sex, lives of watermelon.
Something interesting about chrysanthemums.
I don't know why choose a Martian invasion radio
show from 1938 old old, old gay,
well I guess it's a valid question you ask. Truth is,
I actually only discovered the war of the worlds recently in 2001 actually not
long after that day in 2001 and it just really struck me and it wasn't so much
that the broadcast had a kind of end of the world notice that I guess we were
all feeling in real life at that moment,
but it was more just the way that the story unfolded step by step by step and
how in the broadcast you feel like you were lost inside a newscast,
which is not unlike what it was like we were all, you know,
glued to the TV in real life, grasping at these pieces of news,
trying to figure out what was going on. And that was very much,
I think what they were trying to create in the broadcast. But now,
many years later, what I'm really left with is a question, what?
Well,
if I were alive in 1938 in front of the radio and I heard this sounds,
what would I have thought? Would I have believed it? I mean, I don't know.
What about you? I don't really know. I don't really know. Okay,
well let's do something. Let's actually go back to 1938 and, uh,
see if we can figure out how these sounds landed on people's ears and what
information they had in their heads. So, and I need your help with this.
How would I help with that? Yeah. You,
I want you to go over to that seat right there. That's,
we're going to call that seat in 1938 all right there. Okay.
Now just, let's just all imagine there you are on your easy chair.
You're maybe drinking a cream soda.
Let's tune the dial. Okay.
[inaudible]
okay, I've got something on the dial.
Good evening,
ladies and gentlemen from the Meridian Room in the Park Plaza Hotel in New York.
Today we bring you the music of Raman [inaudible] and his orchestra.
Who is Rick Marge, you know, a Raymond ruck. Hello.
The doctors, the Spanish Raymar [inaudible] with lower cupboard.
Nope.
You don't know that there's no such person as Ramon Rick, hello. And Net.
It's just a record and a CBS studio, but it sounds professional enough.
So you sit back, you relax. But then
ladies and gentlemen,
we interrupt our program of dance music to bring you a special bulletin from the
Intercontinental Radio on you at 20 minutes before eight central time,
refactor Pharrell at the mouth, getting the observatory reports,
observing several explosions,
but then can definitely get occurring at regular intervals on the planet Mars.
The spectroscope indicates the gas will be hydrogen and moving toward the earth
with enormous velocity,
not returning you to the music of Ramrod Kilo playing for you in the Meridian
Room of the Park Plaza Hotel situated in downtown New York.
[inaudible].
So at this point you think I'm thinking explosions on Mars,
hydrogen moving towards earth.
A little strange,
but how could it be so bad if I still get to listen to the fabulous nodes of the
lovely Raymond? You go to that color
and he does continue to play for another minute, 34 seconds.
But then it happens again.
Ladies and gentlemen, following on the newest,
given an iron bullet in the moment ago,
the government media or logical bureau has requested the Lord.
Now before we go ahead and leave it there for, are we going to get further?
Let me ask a really basic question here. I mean, we're dealing with a play,
a radio play. Yeah.
Why would Orson wells in his posse of have troubadours start their play this
way?
The original,
each Gul story was written in 1898 so it was really an old book at the time and
there, there is no reporter character in the book. By the way,
does everybody know this word? The world story. And most people do.
The story basically is this little green creatures from Mars for a number of
reasons having to do with thirst or something,
have to leave their planet and they come to Earth. They're not very nice people.
They invade, they destroy quite a number of us.
And then ironically in the end they get killed by little viruses,
our smallest inhabitants of our planet, bite them and destroy them.
And it's science fiction of course. But in 1938 most kids knew this story.
It was very popular. So I don't see why.
Right. And in fact,
let me bring in a clip from a Orson wells producer at the time, John Houseman,
uh, Austin and I chose it. We decided the time had come,
we should be doing a science fiction show. And so we tried a few of that one.
Very easy to do.
Just a few days before they had to be on the air with their next installment.
John Houseman pulls that book off the shelf to shows it to o w says, Hey,
what about this? And Orson Welles says this,
you want me to do this? Oh, he, uh, had trouble in what sense? In the sentence?
No, he said he was barring, uh, if it was something that happened 50 years ago,
everybody knows it didn't happen. So, uh, who the hell cares,
right?
We're gonna make people care about this old story. We've got updated not 18, 98,
1938. And it just so happened that one month prior,
something had happened that forever changed the world in the news.
What was that? We'll begin with the story.
The trains go by dies. [inaudible] I bought it.
[inaudible]
Hitler was threatened in Europe, first Austria,
then Czechoslovakia World War Two was right around the corner and cvs sent a
team of guys to cover this story among them, Edward, right
where Allambia continues with expensive coverage of a European car.
And in September Moreau and his CBS producers did something with the news that
was kind of novel. The broke in.
We interrupt this program of music by Harry James and his orchestra to bring you
a bullet in just received. And that w o r knew his role.
No, this had happened before, but never quite like this with life reports,
eye witness accounts and never quite so much
where up their broadcast to bring it up in Portland, probably night of prep
and just one month. These buildings have become so numerous.
We interrupt our program to bring you a special broadcast.
That bulletins were practically interrupting bulletins.
We interrupted the program to bring you a special broad,
let me interrupt this broadcast to bring her this in parking bulletin from the
United Bread
program to take it in the NBC News Room [inaudible] on the NBC.
So after weeks and weeks of hearing these constant interruptions,
it's easy to understand why this play. [inaudible]
the gentlemen following on the news, given an off,
we'll live in the moment of goal, didn't sound like a play,
but Gavin loved meteorological bureau has requested the large observatories of
the country to keep on Astronomical Watch on any further disturbances occurring
on the planet Mars. We have arranged an interview with a noted astronomer,
professor Pierson,
who will give out his views on this event and a few moments we will take you to
the principal observatory at Princeton, New Jersey.
We return you until then for the meal take of Grandma and rock yellow and the
door.
I don't know whether I need anymore. Raymond. Marcelo,
I need to know a little more about this motion. Uh,
isn't it interesting how slowly it starts and by the way, um,
what time do you got on your, uh, your a pocketwatch there? Uh,
the pocket watch says eight Oh four eight oh four.
Tell me when it gets the eight oh five to what? Eight oh five to eight.
Oh five. Eight oh five
and no,
this is my favorite minute in understanding one of the greatest media hoaxes of
all times. Cause it's the thing that's interesting is that at this moment in uh,
October of 1938 art,
Orson wells in the mercury theater of the air were not that popular.
They had a tiny, tiny slice of the audience.
And so not too many people were listening. Certainly not at the beginning.
From eight o'clock to eight Oh four.
And so not too many people heard this very important introduction,
the Columbia Broadcasting System and its affiliated stations.
Was that the war of the world by h g [inaudible]
what? Wait. Why didn't they hear that? Well cause at that very same moment,
the majority of people listening were tuned into this.
The bakers of Jason Sanborn copied his super gland, you know,
is fresh present the chase and Sanborn out
that chase and sandbar now, now that that was good. That was Ed Bergen.
It had the puppet, Charlie McCarthy Mu who liked girls.
It was as high as it's rated. It was the most popular show at the time.
Right opposite.
Agreed Theater of the year had 10 times the audience,
but at eight oh five host Donna Meechie introduces not so popular singer
and it's the rousing rip roaring song of vagabonds from La Vagabond. Jake.
Aw, yours mega love raffle up
and yes, at that moment thousands, hundreds.
We don't know how many listeners started to dial surf
where they landed on the mercury theater of the air already in progress where
they stayed.
We are ready now to take you to the principal observatory at Princeton
because by then a strange meteor had landed
where Carl Phillips,
our commentator will interview with Professor Richard Pearson,
famous astronomer. The IB cannot question at any time.
It's better. No.
Quite convinced that the scientists that living intelligence as we know it does
not exist on Mars. Right.
They have the chances against it are a thousand to one and yet how do you
account for these gas eruptions occurring on the surface of the planet at
regular intervals cannot account for it. Just more related.
Yeah.
We've had four interruptions now at this point you've called your whole family
into the room.
Marge media is on media is on Mars, March.
Meteors why meteors on Mars
and just as you are utterly confused, along comes the expert, you know,
people surveyed afterwards said, I didn't believe this thing.
I thought it was all Bologna until I heard that government official guy or the a
Princeton professor. And this script is chocked full of believable experts.
Great. Or the natural history museum professor [inaudible] Copper,
the California Astronomical Society there, General Montgomery Smith,
Captain Lansing of the signal card.
Maybe subconsciously that had an effect to convince people that something was in
fact happening.
A feeling furthered a moment later when the professor and uh,
the reporter Carl Phillips go live to that field in Grovers mill,
New Jersey with that media, right? Or whatever it is, it's Atlantic.
The metal casing is definitely extraterrestrial.
A not found on the friction with the earth. That must be yours with tears,
holes in the media, right? The thing is moving.
If something's happening, ladies and gentlemen, it's terrific.
And the, the thing is beginning to flake off the top. It's beginning to rotate.
Like a screw in this thing must be hollow.
[inaudible] go the top,
blow out that
[inaudible] problem.
One calling out something I can hang out of that black hole to Illumina's desk
or the eyes might be a space, might be on the phone. Heaven.
Nothing out of the shadow like a gray snake.
That's kind of be shaped like a lie, but gripping sonic swimmer sweatshirt.
I hate written lists. Lips sexually as do I.
Now before we get too far into this, see, let me play you a another clip,
right? Yep. Inviting Majestically Florida like them. Great. Better,
no doubt. [inaudible] a little bit more.
I mean the windows looking down the field ahead of them.
[inaudible] edits, edit pricing. Oh my. Get out of the way, please.
If Bernie bursting into flames and then falling on the morning, bad.
All the humanity and all the faceted Phoebe garage,
this is tape of the Hindenburg crash. Sure. It's still fresh in people's minds.
Happened one year before the broadcast,
before going on the air that night after Frank Reddick who played that reporter,
Carl Phillips in the field, he went to the library,
dug up this old tape or not so old and played it to himself.
Oh, the humanity and all the faceted,
all the humanity and all the predators. Baby Garage, oh,
the humanity and all the fans are just freebie.
Get himself in the right frame of mind for that now famous attack scene in that
field in New Jersey.
Those creatures know what that means about anything
[inaudible] happening. [inaudible] is rising out of the pit.
Then they got a small beam of light against the mirror.
[inaudible] get the frame spangled [inaudible] head on.
Hello did tell you the packed
to the automobiles running everywhere coming. Just point out.
Cool.
The transmission cuts off 12 million people have just heard slithery green
aliens. He visceral [inaudible], policemen, farmers and reporters followed by
nothing.
Ladies and gentlemen, Yoda. Circumstances beyond our control.
We are unable to continue the broadcast from Grovers mill.
Evidently there is some difficulty with our field transmission. However,
we will return to that point at the earliest opportunity
and when they do return,
what you learn is that that grounded flying saucer that just zapped all those
men has now stood up. It's grown legs,
it's as tall as a tree and it is marching
through the countryside, stopping everything in its path.
And then we are taken to field reports, live battles,
scenes between militia and positive. Before we do, let me play one more clip.
This one is real.
If you ran,
and one of the areas you mentioned are the type a child of school age and where
did you have an evacuated? You should send him to school tomorrow.
Friday with hand luggage containing the child got a change of underclothing.
This is Edward r Murrow reporting from London. Same time period.
Just to give you a sense of how scary it was to be alive at this moment in time,
kids in England were being told to take gas masks to school,
all of which would have made the following dramatize battle scenes.
They do now for the field headquarter, the State Mulatto, Robert Mill,
New Jersey,
all the more real [inaudible].
It's 37 degrees.
Here are the New Jersey militia fire on a fleet of Martian pods.
What if only does to no avail.
There shells bounce right off in the margins and release a cloud
or poisonous gas, which slowly overtake the soldiers. Sure
they made us [inaudible]. He touched you.
[inaudible]
ladies and gentlemen,
I have a grave announcement to make incredible as it may seem,
both the observations of science and the evidence of our eyes lead to the
inescapable assumption that those strange beings who landed in the Jersey
farmland tonight are the vanguard of an invading army from the planet Mars.
The Battle of which took place tonight at Grove of mill has ended in one of the
most stopping the feats ever suffered by an army in modern times.
7,000 men armed with rifles and machine gun pit it against the single fighting
machine of the invaders from [inaudible] 129 survivors.
One moment please. Ladies and gentlemen,
another Bolton from Lang and field Virginia amongst it is now in control of the
Middle Section of New Jersey and has effectively cut the state through its
center highways to the north, south and west.
The quad with frantic human please not reserves are unable to control the MED
flight communication lines that down from Pennsylvania to the let it go.
Cracks the tone in service discontinued except Marsha law prevail throughout New
Jersey in eastern Pennsylvania.
Other boats cutting planes report enemy machines down three number increasing
speed north wind kicking over house at the same time we take you to Washington
for the sons of a nation, the secretary of the interior,
I shall not try to conceal the gravity it in.
It handed me a your way auction. Paul ain't going on
[inaudible] now. No more defense.
Everything wiped out.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
we don't know exactly how many people panicked that night.
Here's what we do now.
The Trenton Police Department got 2000 calls in under two hours.
The New York Times switchboard received 875 calls alone from people wanting to
know where they'd be safer.
On the roof or in the gas rate shelter in the cellar. We,
we're lucky we do have transcripts of what happened on the other side of radios
that night,
thanks to a Princeton sociologist who went out and conducted a series of
interviews after the broadcast.
And what's amazing is how effective that broadcast was.
Some listeners said they actually felt like they were choking others reported to
police that they saw with their own eyes.
As they looked at the Manhattan skyline,
they saw a thin veil of smoke from the battle over the city.
Some said they saw Marsha machines' high,
stepping their way down the palisade splash, splash, splash. Uh,
and many people when they called operators or police, they didn't say,
oh my God, we're being invaded by Martians. They said, oh my God,
we're being invaded by Germans.
Here are some of the literal transcriptions.
This is what real people actually say. Everybody ready?
I knew it was some Germans trying to gas us all,
but when they announced or kept on calling them people from Mars,
I just thought he was ignorant.
I immediately called up the Maplewood police and asked if there was anything
wrong. They answer, we know as much as you do.
Keep your radio tuned in and follow the announcer's advice.
Yeah, I called into my husband, Dan, why don't you get dressed?
You don't want to die in your working clothes.
I looked in [inaudible] and saw some chicken left from Sunday dinner that I was
saving for Monday night dinner, said to my nephew,
we may as well eat this chicken. We won't be here in the morning.
This is Dawson Wells, ladies and gentlemen,
out of character to assure you that the war of the world has no further
significant and at the holiday offering it was intended to be.
We annihilated the world before your very ears and utterly destroyed the CBF.
You will be relieved.
I hope to learn that we didn't mean it and the both institutions are still open
for business.
That was how Orson wells concluded the war of the worlds broadcast with those
words basically. Huh? It was a joke. Gotcha.
But it was only after he and his producer,
John has been left and read the papers the next day that they understood just
how much trouble they had caused a disagreeable because of for at least a couple
of hours. We believe we were mass murder,
extremely surprised to learn that a story which is become familiar to children
through the medium of comic strips and uh,
this as well as in the press conference that following day
mini succeeding novels and adventure stories should have had such an immediate
and profound effect upon radio listeners.
So immediate and so profound that the FCC commissioner at the time,
George Henry Payne, labeled the Mercury theater of the air,
get this terrorists
[inaudible]
radio terrorists.
But there is one thing we must not overlap all this took place in 1938 and our
less sophisticated yesterday that did not know the atom bomb guided missiles and
rockets that may shortly fly to the Moon Edward
r Murrow in 1957. Was he correct when he said that?
Where are we really? So on sophisticated in 1938. I mean,
it's so different from now. Wow. Let's see,
can we interrupt this broadcast for some breaking news? Uh, this Justin,
it seems we may have gotten a few things wrong when we, uh,
performed that show many years ago,
most notably just now when I said that the FTC,
a commissioner in 1938 called Orson Welles radio terrorists in his statement,
he certainly suggests that, but if you read it,
it seems he was actually referring to a statement he made about a year earlier
where he was calling radio producers who terrorize children.
He doesn't actually name Orson wells by name. I just botched that.
My apologies. And we have this guy to thank for bringing it to our attention.
Michael Sokolow and I'm associate professor of journalism and communication at
the University of Maine.
And uh,
Michael Sokolow also makes an interesting argument that the panic may not have
been as large as we made it sound. For example, uh,
we state the 12 million people were listening on that night,
which is a widely quoted number and it comes from polling done six weeks after
the war.
The world's first aired Sokoloff suspects that the actual number of listeners is
way smaller and there's no way to know for sure, but he trusts. A poll conducted
that night.
That night when the broadcast was on 5,000 Americans were surveyed by the CE
Hooper Company, the rating survey company.
Why are we bothering with a study done six weeks later after the newspaper tells
everybody that there was this giant panic?
Why don't we look at the surveys that were done that night and the survey that
was done 12 hours later by cvs the following morning? What are the two surveys?
Immediately after,
say the CE Hooper rating survey found 98% of the respondents were not listening
to Orson wells or war of the worlds.
They were listening to the chase and Sanborn hour or their radios were off or
they were listening to another program of the 2% that they found that were
listening to war of the world.
Not a single respondent thought it was a news broadcast.
Sokolow strongly suspects that the panic was actually trumped up by the
newspapers who were trying to sort of piss on this new medium called radio that
was taken away their, you know, audience.
Exactly. Here was the opportunity and a radio.
The radio industry and the newspaper industry had been battling for years and
throughout that decade, the entire newspaper industry had been losing money,
political prestige and other things too. The radio industry, you know,
some of their best employees.
And so they were waiting for a way to really prove to advertisers and prove to
federal regulators, you know, they had the first amendment,
they understood responsibility. These are the newspaper managers.
These radio guys were conflating advertising with programming.
They were frightening their viewers. They were acting irresponsibly.
And remember,
this is a month after Munich when radio prove that news really works on the
radio. Well, one month after radio news comes of age,
suddenly they're conflating news accounts with fiction and they're acting
irresponsibly and they're terrorizing the public.
And so the newspaper industry had the perfect thing to hang their critique of
radio on. Interesting.
And that's interesting. So all those,
all those eye witness accounts that the panic and I thought it was this and I
packed my bags and whatever, whatever.
And all this sort of reports of people miscarrying.
Do you feel like that's all in memory embellished or what?
How do you explain that stuff?
Give you, let me give you an analogy. Okay.
If you were to ask 100 Americans today,
did you see a plane fly into the World Trade Center on September 11th I think
you would get an extremely high percentage of people saying they saw that plane
flying in. But that's because it's part of our national visual memory.
It's really a trauma and it's, it's,
it's the kind of hysteria and panic we're talking about.
So that moment in time and our relationship to the media. Okay.
But if you were to actually find out whose TVs were on live at nine 48 in the
morning that day and who was actually watching,
there would be a discrepancy in that number. Now,
am I saying all those people are lying? All those people are confused. No.
What I'm saying is that the relationship of memory to the media is extremely
complex,
complex indeed,
and we think Michael Sokolov for checking our facts and if you believe as he
does, the 1938 panic was,
well it didn't happen or it wasn't as bad as it sounds then that actually makes
what we talked about next in our live broadcast. Even more puzzling,
we'll be right back with Radiolab live and this is lily from Laken Bagman
Wisconsin.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab is supported by the Netflix film,
the other side of the wind with this,
the last film from legendary director Orson Welles.
It's the story of director J J G Canford who comes back to Hollywood after years
of semi exile in Europe.
He plans to complete work on his own innovative comeback movie,
which as it happens is also entitled the other side of the wind.
It's a cinematic event 40 years in the making.
The other side of the wind on Netflix and in select theaters November 2nd
this is Radiolab. I'm Jen. I have, I'm Rod. I'm Robert Krulwich.
We are in Saint Paul, Minnesota from the Fitzgerald Theater.
Our subject today is the war of the worlds broadcast.
Originally on October 30th, 1938
okay, now I'm gonna ask the house for a show of hands.
Do you think that somebody else could imagine the broadcast using the exact same
script more or less? Also with Martians also invading,
also interrupting the musical things.
Same deal after all the publicity from the 1938 broadcast.
Could you do it twice? Show of hands please. All.
Some of you don't think so. Look, if we could,
if there wasn't another one of these,
what would we be doing for the next 40 minutes or so?
Those of you who've raised your hands? I'd say it's about 75% of you.
You are correct because it has happened again and I want to tell you a story.
It an amazing story, really an underreported
story of a war of the worlds reenactment happened in the mountains of Quito,
Ecuador, 1949 we were very lucky. We had a reporter, Tony Fields,
who happened to be traveling there.
We asked him to do a couple of interviews and he brought back some tape and
played it for me. All right, so Tony set the scene for me. 1949 Quito.
The where's Quito? Quito is the capital of Ecuador.
Quito is in the middle of the mountains in the Andes mountains and small town,
big town. Quito. Now is a big city. At the time it was a pretty small city.
Um,
the word that everybody who I spoke to use to describe the way the Quito was in
1949 was tranquillo. [inaudible].
Keela like tranquil. Exactly. It is what it sounds like.
And Radio Quito was the most popular radio station. [inaudible]
everybody was into it.
So those are your basic ingredients. You've got a small town population,
250,000. You have one major radio station,
which also happened to be in the same building as the one major newspaper,
El Comercio and the leader of the radio station. The guy who ran it,
he a devious fellow by the name of Leonardo Pius.
One day someone shows up with a script for a Orson Welles, not HD wills,
Orson Welles version of war of the worlds, gives it to Leonardo Pius. He reads,
it says, brilliant, we've got to do this here in Quito.
They insert local place names, you know,
so instead of the Martians landing in New Jersey,
they would land in [inaudible], which is on the outskirts of Quito.
They write in parts for government officials, the minister of the interior,
the mayor of Quito actors or real government.
These would be packers doing impressions, doing impressions. That's right. Whoa.
Not only that. Pius got his bosses at the newspaper,
El Comercio to agree to run little articles in the newspaper in the two days
leading up to the broadcast recording that strange objects had been seen in a
sky's over Keith.
Wow.
So he set out to screw with people basically. I mean he was planting paranoia.
It really seems like he wanted people to believe what they were hearing that
night.
Okay.
Okay. So Saturday, February 12th, 1949 the day of the broadcast,
all day long listeners here and announcement windows [inaudible] notice that
there's going to be a special performance duo, Benitez Valencia. No,
they need this Valencia.
They need Valencia at that time were one of the most popular musical acts in
town and [inaudible]
[inaudible]
eight o'clock rolls around Beneatha's Valencia launches into their performance.
They play a few songs
[inaudible]
and suddenly there's an interruption. Wait,
what was that? Well, it turns out that Leonardo, the pies in addition,
the other tricks he had up his
sleeve,
he had a sound effects guy in the corner that was creating this sound like when
it garrison Keillor's guys kind of a thing
that's right. Can keep everyone.
Eventually the music stops and Leonardo Paez comes on the air and says,
[inaudible] please, dear listeners, excuse the technical difficulties.
There seems to be some sort of atmospheric conditions interfering with the
radio, those signal. But you are listening to radio ketosis brought to you by,
you know, such and such. And now back to
[inaudible].
So
we hear another couple of songs and then there's another interruption.
Soon it's laying out the payers again. This time, this time it's a news flash.
So now we're on script. That's right. That's right.
They send pyres out to report from the scene
and pies is doing the play by play. You know, what is it?
Oh my God, the cops in school, you know from the clinicals
and here come the heat. Right
and Zap. Hi, is this fry?
You can wait, wait, wait, wait. Do we have forget reenactments?
Do we have a copy of the, the real broadcast from that night.
All we have are descriptions.
There is no existing recording of what was broadcast that night and,
and you'll understand why in a second.
By all accounts at work
outside, it was sheer Mei.
Everything that happened next happened extremely quickly.
People tore it out into the streets. People were running,
but they didn't know where to run.
The spaceship supposedly was in the north of the city,
but there's black cloud of gas was in the south and a lot of them actually did
what any good Catholic would do. They made a beeline for the church,
which the church, because because they were,
they thought they'd be safe there or, or perhaps,
or perhaps they just wanted to get right with God before the world ended there.
Even reports, and I wasn't able to confirm this,
but there were reports of men confessing to adultery right there in front of
their wives and priests.
Absolving whole crowds at once by Nico in
[inaudible] citizen added to with [inaudible] Lee. This is Jorge by the Ada,
who is a longtime journalist, worked for many years at the newspaper.
He was listening with his family. They all believed it. They all ran outside,
found a taxi cab to the kids in them, ran behind the taxi cab,
Eh, they were gonna [inaudible] the city
[inaudible] and he tells me that he sees going the other way. This convoy,
military trucks filled with soldiers doing real trucks,
real military vans,
real military vans are the real soldiers and cops behind them and they're
screaming towards the north of the city. Where are they going?
They're going to cut the coal yow to fight the Martians. Yeah.
So if you, if you had any [inaudible]
doubt at this point, and once you saw those military events, you were like, oh,
bleep, I've got to get the hell out. Right. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I to be does, does everybody in Kito believe,
didn't someone call the general beforehand?
Say Tonight we're having a broad thing.
The mayor or someone who sounded an awful like the mayor was on the radio saying
Martians are invading the mayor didn't call the general before a no. No. So,
so then what happens at the end of the show?
Assuming it ends the way they always do [inaudible] then what?
Well, they, uh, stormed the radio station.
Let's go ahead. By the time of broadcast ended and it was announced,
but the whole thing was a play.
A huge crowds were in the streets and word that it was a hoax spread pretty
quickly. All that fear turned pretty quickly to anger
by nine 30 is these a few hundred people outside the station?
At some point there's boxers shows out.
There just been a match in the Central Plaza and the boxer shows up and he's
driving this truck and the truck is full of rocks.
These little white rocks is full of rocks. Yeah.
And people start hurling. The rocks at the station,
at the windows and windows are shattering. They managed to break into the,
to the ground floor with a printing presses on there, smashing printing presses.
At some point,
some people in the crowd materialize and they have these flaming torches and it
just goes up like a matched it. So, so, so where people hurt during this
six people died. Oh really? Yeah, most escaped.
There was about 50 people in the building. Most got up to the roof,
jump to adjoining buildings, but six people died according to a reporter, Tony,
uh, one guy or stayed behind the last guy on the air.
That night was a man by the name of Louis Beltran. Maria, are you there?
Yes, I'm here.
Okay. This is Maria Beltran,
Testagrossa a Louis Beltran's daughter and Maria,
you are listening to, to everything that just came before this. Yeah.
Tell us the story from Your Dad's perspective, uh, from here forward.
Uh, well he was, he was on the air. He was the,
I guess hosting the music program and also doing some of the interruption with
the, uh, with the bogus. Uh,
but the point at the point in which the fire started, what was he saying
when he realized the magnitude of the situation?
He went back on the air and began pleading for help pleading for assistance from
the police and the fire department. But as you said before,
no help came because the police were going to fight the Martian. Yeah.
And uh, eventually he was the last one left and uh,
and he jumped out the window.
I'd get from the either the third or fourth floor onto a second floor balcony.
And to break the fall, I guess it's of you want to break the fall.
He grabbed onto the railing of that balcony and he was completely engulfed in
flames at that point.
And the skin on his hands just remained on the balcony.
It was like a barbecue grill. And uh,
from there he jumped to the ground, but before he jumped,
he was pleading to the crowd to I guess catch him, but they didn't.
He landed on some meds, uh, broke legs,
arm ribs, everything, and compounded by the very,
very serious burns that he had all over his body.
So he landed at the feet of an angry mob. What a dick
mob. And He, uh,
he recall that as he's losing consciousness, he just heard somebody say,
just, just let him die in peace. Although some of the articles that I read,
they try to throw him back into the building. Really.
Someone grabbed him and put him in a jeep to take him to the hospital.
Just a bystander. And you know,
he had so many scars here as children, like my brother and I would,
we'd play with his scars.
You would trace them with our finger and ask them what happened.
You know how we got the scars and he would tell us about the fire.
What would he tell you? The whole story or how much of this did you know?
Dory, he would just give us in just in broad terms,
but he had been in a building that caught fire, uh, as children.
We didn't really ask him. Maybe had we been older and asked them,
he would have told us the whole story.
Hmm.
And we should say that your dad stayed behind to try and help other people get
out of the building. Well, let me ask you a question though. Uh,
your dad obviously is a hero,
but given the fact that he was one of the voices that created the panic,
did he feel some sort of ambivalence about,
I don't know, in retrospect whether he did or not,
I'm sure there must've been some ambivalence. But from what I understand,
the story was kept,
it was very top secret so that even the employees did not know what was going to
be broadcast during that music program. Really.
I don't know at what point he was informed of the detail.
So I don't know really how we felt about it.
I wish I had had an opportunity to ask him.
MMM. Well listen, Maria,
thank you so much for your time and joining us here and yeah. Thanks. Perfect.
Aye. Aye.
Want to know what happened to the guy who planned the hoax? Uh, well, uh, he,
uh, he got out through the roof like a lot of others.
He hopped to the next building, hit out for a few days,
and then fled the country to Venezuela. Never to return,
never to return, never to return.
But I should say that among the six people who died that night was his
girlfriend
and a nephew of his. Okay.
So the 1949 kito broadcast caused a whole lot of trouble.
The 1938 New York broadcast caused a whole lot of trouble.
Now everybody here before who raised their hand and thought that this could
happen again, you are right again, Lau,
buffalo, 1968
[inaudible] for the time it's sales.
Kind of like your basic Eja set until you hear this. What is your Joe Down here?
And it'd be something here that I'm must supposed to read. Thank you.
Thank you Jo. Uh, let's see. The NASA, NASA,
the national space in there and not access administration.
Those people have alerted all their space watch and, uh,
facilities to be on the alert for unusual communication difficulties tonight,
I suppose before the Federal Agency referred to the explosions on the planet
Mars and said it was not known if they would have the same effect on earth
communications as similar explosions on the surface of the sun have,
I guess I talking about sun spots and things like that. So, uh, I dunno, it, it,
you know, it,
it means that it's going to be hard to hear communications from NASA.
I don't know.
Can you hear me? Daughter's South Carolina. Lord,
you can hear Kv whatevers you make about communication.
Can you take what you're hearing on a week night,
getting it all together where you double you?
W K BW broadcast followed the same structure as the original broadcast.
We've heard tonight long stretches of music than the news bulletins than the
semi realistic field reports. Here's one of them.
Oh my God, you got walking injuries or are real bad.
You got the same vivid descriptions of Martian.
Hi My god, we all got a dog
and according to the station manager Jeff K, he gets the same outcome.
People bought it.
Hello, hello.
Police and telephone company reported to Wk VW that they received more than
4,000 phone calls.
The Canadian military authorities dispatched military units to the Peace Bridge,
the Rainbow Bridge, and the Queenstown Bridge to repel invaders.
The story was carried the next day by 47 newspapers in the countrywide and on
the night of the show and during the show in 90 press bureaus up and down the
east coast of America,
a besieged by phone calls asking about the Martian invasion and buffalo.
Incredible. You're absolutely right. It is incredible.
[inaudible]
thanks to the folks at Wk BW buffalo for that. What is this music, by the way?
This is the disco version of war of the worlds 1978
there's a disco version. Still sells a lot of copies. You'd be surprised.
Here's the obvious question to ask.
Why does this keep working? Well, that's a difficult question.
I came across a psychology professor, I'm Richard Gehrig,
I'm a professor of psychology and the cognitive experimental program at Stony
Brook University.
He has this notion Richard Gehrig does and it root people are suckers for
stories. We just cannot help ourselves. When a story starts,
you just kind of go, whoa.
I think the norm is to fall into the story and that it's unusual to sort of
teach yourself from falling it. My favorite example is a,
there's a scene in gold finger boom.
Yeah, for the all time best James Bond movie.
I think we're bond is tied down spread eagle on a piece of metal and there's
this laser coming toward him which really looks like the to cut them into.
And even as I'm saying that right now,
I'm starting to feel a little bit of anxiety cause there's a picture get in my
head. I'm picturing that laser coming toward him and you know, spoiler alert,
he doesn't actually get split into by the laser yet. Sorry.
But here's the thing.
Go and watch the movie now and see if you can get through that scene without
experienced suspense.
And it really seems to say something very powerful and strong about how immerse
we can become in the narrative world.
[inaudible]
this is Ashley Aztec calling from Modesto, California.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
this is Radiolab. I'm Jad boom rod. And I'm Robert Krulwich and this
is the sound of 700 people who come to bear witness to the recording of our show
today. We are in the Fitzgerald Theater at Saint Paul,
Minnesota talking about these strange phenomenon that is the war of the worlds.
You know, I, it's very great that everybody's here, of course. But this I,
there's one guy I really wish had been here. The Ecuadorian Guy Leonardo. Well,
let's just, because he, he's the guy I want to ask. Like,
what were you thinking?
Well, he's dead.
He's dead. Yeah. Well, but how Orson Wells, I would say to him,
what were you thinking? I would say dead had. Yeah.
So I found a guy who I think is definitely alive.
I am Daniel Myrick co-writer,
Co director of the Blair witch project before making the Blair witch project.
And my Rick heard a recording of the war of the worlds.
He was pretty young at the time. He was a teenager.
I just thought it was brilliant.
I absolutely the coolest thing and more than anything else,
he was impressed by the technique of the thing.
There's a couple of moments in particular where they cut to the kind of onsite
reporter telling you to call fill ups that drover's. Yeah,
it's almost like cut in a second or two early and you hear the reporters saying,
so are we on my eye? Are we, are we gonna Ladies and gentleman?
And then he goes into his into character.
Here I am back with stone wall and it says little beats,
a little moments that really make it convincing.
I get this kind of guilty excitement when I,
when I know how it affected people and he was fascinated by the idea that scary
stories get even scarier if you think they're true. So years later,
fresh out of film school,
he and his friend Eduardo Sanchez decided to develop their own a wells like
products. Your basic scary, which story? Three a kids go into the woods.
Hey, okay, we're leaving right now. They get lost.
They bumped into the witch and then they die or they think they die.
You never see them again.
But when you entered the theater to see the bear, which project,
the first thing that you'd see on the screen are these two sentences.
In October of 1994 three student filmmakers disappeared in the woods near
Burkittsville, Maryland while shooting a documentary. A year later,
their footage was found.
So the suggestion here is that what we see might be real
well,
we picked a subject matter that was difficult to disprove to the casual
observer. Martians invading from outer space is you turn the channel to the next
networking.
If no one's reporting about it pretty well assured is probably fiction,
but three missing students in the woods, you know,
that's something that is a little harder to disprove without a fair amount of
scrutiny. And it worked.
We were getting calls from police wondering where these three kids were and how
come they never heard of this case? You're kidding. Oh yeah.
I mean it was constant.
We still getting emails occasionally on what part of the story is real.
You know, is there still any phenomena out in Burkittsville and DA, da Da. Dot.
All fiction and is all made up.
And I think it reinforces what I think Ed and I suspected that so much of us
wants to believe.
Some people told Dan Myrick that after watching the sweet campers go in the
woods, they themselves would never go camping again.
And he thought that was fabulous. He loved rule. Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa,
Whoa, whoa, Whoa, whoa. Why would you not want people to go camping?
I mean, we know honestly. Why would you do that to people? Well, I asked him,
I mean, that's why you're doing it. You know,
we're not making this movie to kindest scare people.
We were making the film to really scare people.
No regrets on people not wanting to go camping afterwards.
So
the question is, is that what Orson Welles was up to back in 1938?
Was he just trying to give people a good old fashion show business scare,
make them scream away, up in the balcony.
Cause remember at the time that is what he claimed,
that this was simply an entertainment.
This is Dawson Wells, ladies and gentlemen,
out of character to assure you that the war of the world has no further
significance and it's the holiday offering.
It was intended to be the mercury theater,
his own radio version of dressing up in a sheet and jumping out of a Bush and
saying boo.
16 years later, Orson wells changed the story.
Here he is on the BBC. The year is 1955
in fact, we weren't as innocent as we meant to be.
And we did the Martian broadcast.
We were fed up with the way in which everything that came over,
this new magic box, the radio was being swallowed. So in a way,
our broadcast was an assault on the, uh,
credibility of that machine.
We wanted people to understand that they shouldn't swallow everything that came
through the tap.
So here are two ways to think about the war of the worlds. One,
it was a smashing entertainment using every trick they could think of including
inventing some new ones to scare you.
Silly master storytelling or or,
and it was, we're trying to send you a warning.
Don't trust everything you hear on the radio. It's not always true too.
Which one was it you think? Well,
I asked the professor Jason Lavilla [inaudible] me. Yeah, you Jason Him.
He's a radio historian at the University of Maryland.
He says that what Welles understood was that a newscast is often two things at
once in a newscast. You hear something scary or disturbing sometimes,
but it's going to be told to you in a way that sues you,
meaning the authority of the voice, the newscasters,
steady voice coming through the radio.
It will calm you like President Roosevelt's famous fireside chat
friend.
I want to prop for a few minutes with the people of the United States about
banking.
When you studied the rhetoric that Roosevelt used,
he really did convey two messages.
One were in terrible danger and too, I've got it covered.
And that is the sort of the, the authoritative voice coming out of the darkness,
this sort of invisible, disembodied voice of the powerful man. Um,
the news anchor, September 22nd,
1940 and we'll see this with Moreau on the rooftops.
Rick standing on a roof top during the plane looking out over London straight in
front of me. Now you hear two sounds and just a moment are
he's giving us a story of an unfolding emergency,
I should think in a few minutes. There may be a bit of shrapnel around here,
but his mastery of the information, his mastery of his own voice,
his bravery on the scene.
You may be able to hear the sound of guns off in the distance, very frankly,
like someone kicking a tub. But this was the big [inaudible]
getting of the formatting of fear,
the formatting of crisis.
And so people go to the news not to be afraid,
but to be afraid. And then to be reassured,
Robert [inaudible] you file things for the news. Yeah.
Do you buy this that a news reporter does these two things simultaneously scares
and then reassures and then scale. You never go, you know,
go cover the governor and say, first I'm going to scare them,
but then I'm going to assuage them, you know, when would do that?
Why else would you talk that way? I mean not you,
but I mean the form in of the news is a,
because the guy is always there because he's an anchor.
That's what the word means.
It is a reassuring thing to see them night after night telling and telling,
but loving Leo says that the real genius of the war of the was that wells put
you into a newscast where you expect anchors to anchor and you expect reporters
to report and then he kills the reporter and the anchor and suddenly you're left
all by yourself in your own living room all alone.
Okay.
That is exactly right. The moment of the war of the worlds broadcast,
which still frankly terrifies me. It's this moment, right? Yeah.
Here by some head on to tell you to play
by the words, the
running every way coming to find out about 20 yards. Right?
It's like that silence is terrifying. No anchor, no reporter,
no one to reassure you. Okay,
but forgetting that for a moment.
What about his second lesson that he had to teach us the thing about don't
believe the radio. What about that? Did it work?
Well, Professor at Louisville, Leo says,
if that is really what wells was trying to do, if you believe that,
well then he failed. Actually, he worse than failed the war of the worlds.
Not once, not twice. We've shown you three broadcast tonight.
It was so good at grabbing an audience and sucking them in that the wills
formula,
you might call it the newscast that scares you enough to keep you listening has
been adopted by of all folks news
right now at 11 and nine of shopping during the two. One night of fear,
swarming over borders, flooding cities and towns, Muslim immigrants, teens,
texting and driving.
It's a deadly mixed terror in the toilet and sink holes and landslides.
Python in the cod,
a rapid baby go terrorists working at one of our airports,
timber in the toilet, pythons in the potty. He may be,
there will be true snake somewhere near a toiletry facility of some kind.
But it probably wasn't the python and it probably wasn't your toilet,
but you don't know that.
You want to hear that it belongs to Mrs. James C McGillicuddy of 2114 boday
boulevard and not you. So you,
you want to be reassured and so you listen and so you fall Ian.
And if Orson Welles retelling a Martian invasion story by hg wells that most
people already knew, if he could grab us
and then if they could do it again in Ecuador and then if they can do it again
in Buffalo, what does that tell you? It tells you that we can't help ourselves,
even if the headline is slightly preposterous, even if it's slightly scary,
even if it's slightly false,
we will listen.
The fear that these broadcasts generate now suck us in.
And you'd think that 70 years later we'd be more sophisticated and critical.
When the local newscaster tells us that there's something we're feeding our
children that could kill them, and they'll tell us after the news, the we,
I still listen.
I'm a media critic and I still wait through the commercials to see what is it
that I'm doing to kill my child. Even if it's really implausible,
your shoelaces will kill you after this beat method. I somehow,
it gets me every time. Yeah.
And wells knew
[inaudible].